so
hello you're watching entertainment week
coming up on the show
british rock royalty johnny marr reveals
the inspiration behind his new album
mackenzie crook on how a passion for
metal inspired his latest series
rising soul star quavs performs his
latest single here in the studio and can
ben affleck's gone girl live up to the
hype we'll give you our verdict
first risque pop stars have been getting
protective parents hot and bothered for
years but recently there's been growing
concerns about the impact raunchy music
videos have on young minds now three
major uk labels as well as youtube and
vivo have signed up to a scheme which
introduces age ratings for videos online
here's just some of the artists and
clips that have been causing offence
that's how we follow
well i'm joined now by associate editor
of the sunday times magazine chrissy
morrison and the singer quartz great to
see you both chrissy what do you think
of the new initiative is any good um i
can't really see how it's going to work
if i'm honest i mean this has always
been the way
music videos have always caused
controversy um you know when i was when
i was at school it was britney spears
yeah madonna before that
so it's all this isn't a new thing by
any stretch of the imagination what's
different is that before tv controllers
could decide what time of the day or
night they were going to run things and
that that control is gone now but i also
think we have to put it in perspective
that in the scheme of things that
kids can go out and readily find on the
internet
a little bit of naked flesh or a lot of
naked
a little bit of naked
naked
your videos are definitely not as bad as
any of these i mean what do you think
would you be happy to have age ratings
on your videos
um i think it's a nice idea but i think
in practice it doesn't doesn't sound
like it would really work i think i
don't think i don't think you can
control everything and i think um like
you were saying you know ultimately you
end up with a situation where
um you make the restricted stuff feel
really kind of enticing and kind of you
give it an allure that maybe you don't
want to be there do you think some
artists will try their best to be as
salacious as possible to get that 18
rating hey i wouldn't put it past some
people i think i think you know
you don't want to put it you don't want
to make it something that is a desirable
status you know
um
you know i think i think the videos
the videos their their their art you
know um some people would say um but i
think ultimately if if you have a
problem with what's inside the videos
you know the idea that they're
misogynistic or violent then it's more
about educating young people as to what
the correct way to to uh to think about
those things or behave is rather than
just cutting off all
um viewing of those things doesn't make
any sense and at the moment this is only
voluntary and it's also only there for
uk artists some of the worst offenders
are the americans are there so in some
ways it sounds a bit toothless it's it's
there are many flaws in this plan um
only for uk artists only the three major
record labels have signed up and i think
that's the the most controversial videos
when i was young actually a lot of them
came out the independent labels um and
also it only goes through it's only
things being shown on vevo and youtube
those are the ones that i've signed up
to at the moment so there are so many
other ways to access these videos
without this rating on them if you
wanted to and actually if the idea of
this is to make parents better informed
then surely that's the potential of
giving a very mixed message of what is
and isn't appropriate thank you both so
much and kwabs will be hearing your new
single at the end of the show thank you
thank you
time now to catch up on the rest of the
week's entertainment news there is flash
photography coming up
radio dj dr fox was arrested over
allegations of sexual assault against
two women he's vowed to clear his name
george clooney married british lawyer
amal al-madin at a star-studded wedding
in venice the happy couple waved to
onlookers and photographers after making
their marriage official at the town hall
lindsay lohan made her west end debut
and speed the plow to a mixed reception
after forgetting a line one critic
called her a bit of an embarrassment it
took just 14 minutes for the first batch
of tickets for glastonbury 2015 to sell
out the headliners won't be announced
until next year and a local council
inadvertently painted over a banksy
mural after complaints it was offensive
and racist it was thought to be worth
around four hundred thousand pounds
not many of our guests can lay claim to
the title godlike genius but that's
exactly the award the enemy bestowed on
johnny marr last year the guitarist
influenced generations of musicians as
the founding member of one of britain's
most seminal bands the smiths as well as
bringing his talents to groups like
electronic and the cribs but it was only
in 2013 that he finally released his own
album and he's clearly got a taste for
the solo life as he's already back with
another
and johnny mart joins us now johnny
lovely to see you thanks for inviting me
now two solo albums in two years why on
earth did it take you so long to go solo
i was busy
doing lots of other things
um that i really enjoyed
all the bands that i've been in
were great fun and
real commitment it wasn't a matter of
there was a solo career in waiting or
something that i always aspired to
i was just really happy doing what i was
doing i really loved the collaborations
and then
i just wanted to do something different
so i
made my own record it's quite
philosophical i mean what do you want
people to bring away from the album
because there's stuff about consumerism
in there there's stuff about the pursuit
of money
basically i was i was wondering whether
the things that we pursue
to
possibly escape
boredom loneliness
detachment all these things whether in
fact that pursuit
is the reason why we have those symptoms
in the first place so there's
some call this tension
you know so the idea really is like that
we live in this kind of cultural loop
like we're chasing to get away from
something that is actually caused by the
chase
and um
you know you've got to sing about
something right
you've influenced so many young artists
and you can see your influence in a lot
of their sounds but maybe not in so much
in the sentiment
it seems that young musicians don't have
as much to say as you did and you do now
i mean why do you think that is
i don't know whether they don't have as
much to say i think just maybe what i'm
saying is a bit more more overt i think
i'm singing perhaps more directly about
what i see in society
um
you know something like easy money for
example on the face of it is a pop tune
and i was very
um interested in writing something
really catchy
because i thought to write something a
bit downbeat about money would be
somewhat slightly kind of pompous
so i like the idea of writing and
wrapping it up in a pop tune um
but
there is the underlying you know i do
mention
tuition fees or cash for a degree in
there and i do mention people making the
money on the streets and
um
so in that way i guess there are some
sociological political
messages snuck in a pop tune
um and i come from a time when
um a lot of people did that um in the
early 80s
uh
it was
almost um
there was almost an unspoken
um ideology amongst all the indie bands
say
um
that
we were all on the same page
and literally the music press as well
we're all on the same page um and that
was
fairly anti-establishment
um i thought maybe now that um
maybe it's considered like passe or um
god forbid dangerous or anything like
that i'm not really flying a flag for
anything like that i'm just trying to
sing what i'm interested in and
hopefully sing
something that um or address topics that
people who like me can relate to i mean
do you think with the election coming up
next year it's more important than ever
for artists musicians to get involved to
make their voice heard
i'd like to think so yeah you know if
it's a rock musician or
film director
um getting across some views that might
otherwise be
say
stifled then especially to a young
audience then then great someone's gotta
make fun of the establishment i think
and you must obviously get asked about
the smiths all the time do you find that
flattering or do you find it quite
frustrating when you're wanting to talk
about other things
um i understand it i mean ultimately i
think if you if you've been lucky enough
to be
in a band that people really love okay
and that are successful then it's
somewhat churlish to you can't really be
bitching about it really you know i mean
what more do you want
um
i'm all right because i'm um personally
because i'm happy with
making new stuff you know
it might be
because because my focus is on new stuff
it's it's all just part of what i'm
doing you know so i
people are really nice about it usually
i mean the worst of people were kind of
slugging it off you know
which they're certainly not and finally
i mean are you ever surprised about the
legacy that this missile oh yeah
absolutely yeah because when we started
out smith's um
we were singing
uh playing
very quite unusual music
you know the very as soon as we the
early stuff right as soon as we started
out was um
pretty uncompromising and odd sounding
things and uh and it broke into the
mainstream and became very popular
but i i wasn't expecting for a minute
that what 100 years later that i'd been
being asked about it
and uh and it's so it's an amazing thing
i'm very very proud of it and
people still love it and still sounds
pretty good well thank you so much it's
great to have you on donnie mark thank
you very much
coming up could the cast of the office
reunite mackenzie crook is here to
respond to the rumors and we give our
verdict on one of the year's most
anticipated movies gone girl
from office oddball to pirate of the
caribbean mackenzie crook's career has
been nothing if not varied and the
inspiration for his latest role is
typically off the wall playing a metal
enthusiast in the detectorists a new
series he's written directed and also
stars in
where you've got roman who's to say you
haven't got saxon as well we all know
there's a saxon ship burial somewhere in
this part of the county we just got to
find it first
saxon horde
that's basically the holy grail of
treasure hunting well no the holy grail
is the holy grail of treasure hunting
well you're going to be pedantic the ark
of the covenant
is the holy grail
and mackenzie joins me now lovely to see
you thank you now this new show is about
metal detectors it's an unlikely source
of inspiration why why do you choose
those
i mean i was i've always been fascinated
by people and their pastimes and their
hobbies and the way they use their spare
time and
and get
very
obsessed and and immersed in in their
interests and and i chose metal
detecting as
as the subject um
but it could easily have been
some other hobby uh you know fishing or
something else but it's it's essentially
a story of two guys they're they're very
good friends and their lives and their
relationships but they escape at the
weekends into this into this absorbing
hobby
and not all metal detectors have been
very happy about your uh
your characterization of them have they
they're really just assuming that i'm
going to be poking fun at them and and
i'm honestly not and i really hope that
they watch it and i really hope that
they see that immediately that it's an
affectionate look
at the past time that i'm really into as
well and i'm really interested so yeah
it was never the intention to to take
the mickey and
i think they're just worried that i
think perhaps they um they're used to
being portrayed as anoraks or whatever
but but this doesn't doesn't do that so
he'll be all right because you've had a
fantastic few years we've seen you in
pirates of the caribbean also game of
thrones and now you've come back to
britain to do this new series was it
nice to come back and how different is
it to work on something like this when
you've been on these huge blockbuster
productions
yeah i mean we had the most idyllic six
weeks in in the english countryside
making it and
you know i've done these these massive
projects but i've quite often found that
it's the smaller projects that
uh people
put most of themselves into it so
they're not doing it for the money
because there isn't much money there so
so everyone who gets involved in it gets
involved because they like the project
and they're passionate about it and and
so the atmosphere on sets is is usually
a lot better on low budget things than
it is on on the big blockbusters so it
was a delight yeah i suppose it's
wonderful being able to do both and to
mix it up absolutely yeah in the last
few years i've had time my life going
from one thing to another and different
sizes of productions and completely
different styles and we're going to see
david brent the movie uh in the next
couple of years we believe will you be
involved in that i don't think so
nobody's been in touch and i really
don't think they will but yeah i'm
fascinated to see that as well i mean
that's going to be that's going to be
the about the life of of david brent
post the office so you know i really
don't think he's going to go back and
visit uh tim and dawn and gareth and see
what they're up to because they won't be
interested in them unfortunately and
what about pirates of the caribbean well
there is apparently well they're getting
together a fifth one at the moment and
my agent has been contacted to see if
i'm available which i potentially am
next year so
that's as far as it's gone at the moment
but we'll see so yeah maybe i'll be back
back on a beach how wonderful yeah from
rainy britain into the caribbean
mackenzie thank you so much thank you
great to see you
time now to see what's on at the cinema
this weekend and if there's one film
everyone is talking about it's gone girl
starring ben affleck
so your wife has no friends here is she
kind of standoffish ivy league rubs
people the wrong way she's from new york
she's complicated she's
got very high standards type a
well that can make you crazy if you're
not like that you seem pretty laid back
type b
speaking of which amy's blood type
god i don't know i have to look it up at
the house you don't know if she has
friends you don't know what she does all
day and you don't know your wife's blood
type sure you all are married
film critic rihanna dylan joins me now
to give her verdict rihanna i have read
the book to this i haven't seen the film
yet
people are raving about it is it fair is
it any good okay so i am in the same
boat as you i read the book before going
to see the film and if you're also in
that boat i think you might walk out
like i did finding it a little bit flat
just because the whole point of gone
girl is this amazing psychological
thriller with so many twists and turns i
mean every possible scenario you could
think of is sort of in there whether
it's in your imagination or it's
actually in the film so if you know
what's coming it does ruin it a little
bit because there are so many films
where in some ways we know the endings
and it doesn't ruin it so i mean films
like the fault in our stars that's
incredible i didn't feel flat coming out
of that at all whereas in this although
the performances are amazing rosalind
pike notably has been talked about a lot
because she is such a blank canvas i
think i think that's why david fincher
really went for her and that's why she's
perfect as amy nick and amy's uh
marriage looks perfect on the outside
inside is just completely rotten
you said she's a blank canvas why
because i think she never really gives
anything away she always seems quite
cool quite calm quite calculated and as
amy that's exactly what she needed to be
so i don't think that fans of the book
will be disappointed with her
performance okay earlier in the week we
spoke to osmond pike who plays amy dunn
the toll it took on me was was a was
quite profound because there's
you know i had to play me at different
stages i also had to do some
weight gain and weight loss multiple
times during the six months that we were
filming
and that takes a certain
physical toll on the body um
and sort of mentally
i just was totally immersed in that
world for a long time so that's
interesting she's talking about the toll
it took on her physically and mentally
because it's an incredibly intense story
isn't it it is and as an audience member
you are going to go through a lot with
these characters you go on a real
journey with nick played by ben affleck
who i think is spot on as an
all-american guy who you know has kind
of lost his way a little bit or quite a
lot but i just love the suspense and the
tension that's built up throughout i
think it's a really really interesting
thriller
possibly not for people who've read the
book
possibly not obviously that's not the
film's fault
okay um next film is dracula untold
before before you give us your verdict
let's take a look
no stop it
we can't strike down whoever did this to
you
i chose this
this strengths you sought
but why
because i send corpses back to mehmet
instead of our son
so dracula has been told so many times
over the years what new does this tell
us or what does it do that no one else
has okay so it started i suppose we all
know the bram stoker version of dracula
but he actually took his inspiration
from vlad the impaler uh you know real
character in life he was really quite
vicious and killed a lot of people and
this is where this story comes from so
it's kind of gone right back it's almost
like a marvel origin story in that sort
of way it goes almost
like greek mythology at times because
they do some really quite epic battles
you can see going on behind me it's not
so much
horror even though it looks quite
terrifying i loved how passionate luke
evans got in this film as dracula he
obviously tried to do so much with it
and i think it really worked because he
wasn't the sort of pale-faced demon that
we all imagine when we think of dracula
he's that quite sexy sophisticated very
strong man brilliant a sexy vampire we
like that okay and finally um life after
beth what's this all about okay so you
know that whole newish genre of a zombie
rom-com they've done it again this time
though with aubry plaza who i think is a
fantastic comedian she's very very good
as best she's very deadpan which works
really well as playing a zombie it'll
make you smile i'm not sure it's going
to make you laugh loads
so film of the week it's got to be gone
it's gonna be a young girl of course it
is thank you very much rihanna thank you
that's nearly all for this week on next
week's show british pop diva jessie ware
will be performing here in the studio
and kelly from block party will be
telling us about life after the band and
his new solo album but before we go
we're joined in the studio by the hotly
tipped soul singer kwabs who's here to
play us out with his new single walk
make me blind
all of your pleasures catching my eye
if i jump once then i'll never think
twice but your temptation making me stay
another night and my sister's
gotta take a minute
now
stops i'm gonna keep on
until i end up in the place that i
belong
to get you up my head so i
is
if
no way
hey
no no
no no no no no no no